hey uh we didn't need to wait a year
into Donald Trump's presidency or a
month into Donald Trump's presidency
just hours after becoming president
elect Donald Trump has already gone
against his campaign promise to be the
outsider guy was going to do something
different in Washington Donald Trump has
brought in the same lobbyist influence
peddlers that he ran against Trump ran
on I'm gonna break the Washington
insider control we're gonna stop
politics as usual
no Cruz no Rubio these insiders no no no
I'm gonna do something different
actually saying our movement is about
replacing a failed and corrupt political
establishment with a new government
controlled by the American people I
think you know what's coming
trump broke that promise within hours I
would love to hear from the Trump
supporters who voted for Trump for
something different let's look at the
Trump transition team members put your
seat belts on get your barf bags out get
the kids out of the room Trump
transition team members Michael
Catanzaro lobbyist for Koch Industries
and Disney Eric uhland a prior goldman
sachs lobbyist now working with the
Trump transition team William pallet
uchi a lobbyist who has represented such
nice mom-and-pop companies that
represent America like Aetna
and Verizon also rounding out the team
corporate lobbyists Rick Holt Christine
Ciccone rich bagger that's a fitting
last name and Mike Ferguson yeah real
change huh people criticizing Obama
promised hope and change and it was more
of the same look at Donald Trump
bringing in the exact same types of
people he said he would not bring in and
Trump for America incorporated as a
non-profit chaired by New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie that is
overseeing the Trump transition they're
moving ahead they're meeting with
special interest groups they're reaching
out to lobbyists and you know where
they've been meeting they've been
meeting at the
offices of notorious lobbying firm Baker
Hostetler they had a nice little
breakfast and who was there oh you know
ed Engel and Steve Hart two lobbyists
who have been working to promote the
trans-pacific partnership it's over
folks
everything you voted for change
anti-establishment shake up Washington
it was a lie it's the same old thing
it's Republican crony capitalist
plutocrats how is this going to help how
is the Aetna lobbyists how is the
protein PP lobbyists going to help the
little guy in Louisiana who voted for
anti Washington Trump to make America
great again this is the same type of
team that led the Bush administration
transition that destroyed the economy
you've been bamboozled Trump's decision
to embrace lobbyists while denouncing
them on the campaign trail should not
surprise anyone who's been paying
attention but a lot of these trumpeters
suspended their disbelief or maybe they
never had it to begin with pat and it's
over ours we don't have to wait for the
inauguration we don't have to wait for
the cabinet Trump is doing the exact
thing he said he wouldn't the supporters
have been bamboozled you got a love
house chris Christie is in charge of his
transition team we do of his own cabinet
members in New Jersey were convicted for
closing down a bridge and trying to get
back political retribution it's just so
fitting the entire thing is a sham his
supporters voted for a and he has
already announced the opposite of a so
much for voting for the outsider and
this is worse than what Trump accused
Hillary Clinton of enjoy it folks glad
those poor rural white sand Mississippi
Gulf esteems with Aetna lobbyists and
Verizon they're really gonna make
America work again for that poor white
dude in Mississippi who wants change and
make America great again it is
unbelievable it is disgusting and it is
completely unsurprising in every way
Gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox
360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of other
platforms and you can play as many games
as you want for one monthly fee and if
you find some games you want to keep you
can buy them for a low used price
there's never any due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a free 30-day
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included there's
no contracts and you can rent games
through the mobile app get the free 30
day trial for the David Pakman show
audience and support our show by going
to Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s